KASLIN FIELDS: Hello.
I'm Kaslin Fields, and
I'm a developer advocate
at Google Cloud focused on GKE--
Google Kubernetes Engine-- as
well as open-source Kubernetes.
In this episode of
"GKE Essentials,"
we'll take a look at a key
element of your GKE security
posture--
authorization or access
management, specifically with
regard to workloads.
For a broader look
at GKE security,
be sure to check out our
"Introduction to Securing
Cluster" access video.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
When it comes to GKE, there are
two distinct types or levels
of authorization that you
should be familiar with--
Google Cloud IAM and
Kubernetes Role-Based
Access Control, or RBAC.
The IAM in Google Cloud IAM
stands for Identity and Access
Management.
Basically, IAM
tools are what you
use to set up rules for who
can do what to which resources.
The who in identity
and access management
is going to be some
form of account,
and IAM allows you to set limits
on what that account can do
and with which resources
in Google Cloud.
You can design your
own custom IAM roles.
But, for GKE, there are also
several predefined Cloud IAM
roles to quickly and
relatively easily
provide granular access to
Kubernetes Engine resources.
The GKE Viewer role
gives read-only access,
as might be needed for auditing.
The GKE Developer role is
suited to developers and release
engineers.
It grants full control to all
resources within a cluster.
The GKE Admin role
gives full access
to clusters and the
Kubernetes Engine
resources inside the clusters.
Example users are project
owners, system administrators,
and on-call engineers.
The GKE Cluster Admin role is
used to create, delete, update,
and view clusters, but provides
no access to Kubernetes
resources within the cluster.
You can also create a custom
role in Google Cloud IAM
to create a role with a more
minimal set of permissions
than those that are predefined.
So Google Cloud IAM can be used
to control Google Cloud users'
access to the GKE cluster
and its related resources.
For managing access to
resources within the cluster,
Kubernetes has its
own similar concept--
Role-Based Access
Controls, or RBAC.
Separate accounts are
needed within the cluster
to control cluster
users' access.
Just like with Cloud
IAM, RBAC is the tool
for configuring who
can do what with which
resources within the cluster.
So Cloud IAM lets you manage
who can do what to which
resources at the Cloud
level, controlling access
to the Google Cloud project, GKE
cluster, and other resources,
like Cloud Storage.
Kubernetes Role-Based
Access Control, or RBAC,
manages who can
do what with which
resources within the cluster
on Kubernetes resources
like deployments, persistent
volumes, et cetera.
But what if the thing you want
to give permissions to you
isn't a user, but a workload
running within Kubernetes?
For cases where the who is a
workload, both Google Cloud
IAM and Kubernetes
RBAC have a concept
called a service account.
At this point, it can
get a bit confusing.
There's something called
a service account at both
the Cloud and Kubernetes level.
A Kubernetes service account
is part of your Kubernetes
cluster, and it can be used
to give a workload running
within the cluster access to
other parts of the cluster.
Its scope is contained within
the Kubernetes cluster.
A Google Cloud service account
is part of your Google Cloud
project.
The who of a Google
Cloud service account
can be a Google Cloud resource,
like a GKE cluster, which
can be given permissions via
IAM to access other Cloud
resources.
So what if you have
a situation where
a workload running
within GKE needs access
to some other Google Cloud
resource, like BigQuery?
To get permissions all
the way from a workload
within Kubernetes to
other resources running
in Google Cloud in the
most granular way possible,
another concept is needed to
tie the two service account
concepts together.
That concept is
Workload Identity.
Workload Identity can be
used to automatically connect
a Google Cloud service account
to a Kubernetes service account
so that any workloads
represented by the Kubernetes
service account will have the
access described by the GCP
service account in order
to use any Google Cloud
APIs, products, or services
that workload might need.
Workload Identity
provides granular control,
offering just the
right permissions
to a particular
workload rather than to,
for example, a whole compute
node or a whole cluster,
which may have multiple
workloads running
on them that don't need
the same level of access.
You would configure
Workload Identity
using something similar to
the two commands shown here.
The first command at the
top uses the gcloud tool
to make a call to the GCP APIs
to create a policy binding,
granting the Kubernetes
service account
access to act as the associated
Google Cloud service account.
The second command,
at the bottom,
uses the kubectl tool to use
Kubernetes APIs to annotate
the Kubernetes service account
with the name of the Google
Cloud service account
it will act as.
These concepts can be a
little confusing at first,
but Workload Identity
can help make
access management for workloads
running within your GKE
clusters much smoother
and easier to manage.
In this episode, we talked
about managing access
to resources at the
Cloud and cluster levels
and about simplifying
access management
for Kubernetes workloads via
Google Cloud Workload Identity.
With the concepts
discussed in this video,
we're confident
you'll be on your way
to building a GKE cluster
that suits your needs.
You can get started with GKE
by visiting the Google Cloud
Console and checking
out the links below.
And stay tuned for our next
videos, where we dive deeper
into GKE topics.
[MUSIC PLAYING]